♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
I'm just gonna
come around and say
I don't know how
today's gonna go.
I'm feeling
a little out of sorts.
It's lauded, not "louded."
Nevada, not "Nevahda."
We showed a picture
of Grimace's skeleton.
Someone wrote, "Grimace
wouldn't have a skeleton,
because he's an eggplant."
And I thought,
"That can't be possible."
I mean, though he is
kind of a dick,
but it's grosser
'cause I dug into it,
and according to a McDonald's
manager a few years ago,
Grimace is based
on a taste bud.
And if that's true,
Grimace is just a terrible name.
Anyway, next time
you look at Grimace,
he's that.
[ Laughter ]
I know you might not see
Grimace there,
but we did get a little bit
closer on a taste bud,
and you see him
a little bit better there.
[ Laughter ]
I showed a picture yesterday,
I guess, of a baby with a goatee
and said, "This has been
'Seth puts a goatee on a baby
because the news is so bad',"
some version of that.
Way too many of you jumped out
and said you didn't put
a goatee on a baby,
graphics did.
Don't.
Don't make them your friends.
[ Laughter ]
I see what you're doing,
but don't.
Don't be the teen girl
in a '50s movie
who starts dating the bad boy
to make your parents mad.
Just don't do it.
Baze and I talked about this
after last week's correction.
We talked about, and a lot
of you were surprised --
Timmy never fell down the well
in the TV show "Lassie."
Which is weird because I think
it's what a lot of us
would think was most certainly
a thing that happened
on the show "Lassie."
And this is known
as the Mandela effect,
which is when we believe
a thing to be true
that didn't actually happen.
It was coined in 2009 by a woman
who believed that,
in the '80s,
Nelson Mandela had died in jail.
And then she realized
that a lot of other people
shared that memory of a thing
that didn't happen.
And so a lot of people
have made a list
of certain things
that we get wrong,
such as Timmy falling in a well,
that are examples
of the Mandela effect.
Some famous film and TV quotes.
for example, the line is not,
"Luke, I am your father."
The line is,
"No, I am your father."
That surprised me --
wouldn't you think,
based on every piece
of comedy you've seen,
it's "Luke, I am your father"?
"Beam me up, Scotty,"
never uttered
on the show "Star Trek."
The closest was,
"Scotty, beam me up."
Obviously, the same point,
but I would have put money
on the fact that it was
"Beam me up, Scotty."
And this shocked me
the most of all,
I guess, on this show,
I've never actually said,
"It's time for 'A Closer Look.'"
I say, "Now do 'A Closer Look.'
I don't see why not."
[ Laughter ]
Pence -- we had a version
of Pence getting beamed up.
Built in transitions here
in today's corrections.
But we said,
"Beam me up, Scotty."
And you know, again,
Mandela effect.
And we use the effect,
the beaming effect from
"Star Trek:
The Next Generation,"
which, of course,
Scotty wasn't in.
He was in the original.
So for the person
who pointed that out,
I am sorry
[Nerdy voice]
that you're a nerd. [ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
We mentioned "Doctor Who,"
and the "Doctor Who" fans
reached out to say
we did a great job.
No corrections needed.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
We mentioned
Werther's Originals,
the caramel hard candy.
It's a German company.
I was told by --
And I'm very happy that
we have international viewers.
Let me start by that.
But sometimes I think
they make a correction
based on their language,
not ours,
that the correct
way to pronounce Werther's --
the "H" is silent
and the "W" is pronounced
like a "V".
So, "Verter's,"
but I'm not gonna do that.
[ Laughter ]
I would only do that
if I was saying,
[ Imitating German accent ]
"You will give me the name
of your network of agents.
I recommend you do so
by the time I finished
this 'Verter's.'"
[ Laughter ]
"You have more than an hour."
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Conserve, conserving.
Speaking of Werther's --
"Verter's" --
we talked about how,
if you shot Wether's --
"Verter's" -- out of a gun,
it would puncture Kevlar.
And someone wrote this.
"Anything can penetrate Kevlar
if it's going fast enough.
The speed that a Werther's --
'Verter's' -- Original
would have to go
to penetrate Kevlar
is 37,908.55 meters per second
or 84,799.011 miles per hour,
which is almost 111 times
the speed of sound in air.
This would make a Werther's --
'Verter's' -- Original
the third-fastest
manmade object ever,
placing it behind
a manhole cover --
look it up --
and before the Voyager 1
deep-space probe,
with more than twice
Voyager 1's speed.
Sincerely,
a jackal with a calculator."
A jackal with a calculator,
or as we call them,
"a jaculater."
[ Laughter ]
They get off on doing
their math problems.
[ Laughter ]
I have to correct
my own bad manners.
Our dear friend, colleague,
Jimmy Kimmel
tested positive for COVID.
Had to miss some shows.
Came back on Monday,
and in the monologue
spoke very kindly about
how many people reached out.
Different late-night
hosts went so far as,
say Stephen Colbert,
who does not surprise me,
a lovely man, sent him soup.
He then went on to say
that I did not reach out at all.
I have since reached out
to apologize, but I do --
I'm also gonna fix
this soup problem, and, uh, I...
Devastated that I...
[ Laughter ]
...didn't think to do that.
But we're gonna get it
out to our friend.
Some yummy soup.
Apologies, Jimmy.
Get well soon.
And get well soon to our friend
Stephen Colbert, as well.
COVID does seem
to want to come
for the late-night hosts.
Milli Vanilli.
Sore subject,
especially for Shoemaker.
Used to travel around.
You were like a Deadhead
for Milli Vanilli.
[ Laughter ]
After.
You started following them
after the scandal.
[ Laughter ]
"They got grit."
"Lot of people can't sing,
don't make it as singers."
Um...
So anyway,
we had a Milli Vanilli reference
in the show, and then this
was just an accident,
but we played the track early,
before the callback, and I said,
you know, that's what --
that's how they caught
Milli Vanilli --
they played the track early.
And we were playing
"Blame It on the Rain."
So, couple of things.
Turns out people remember this.
The song was
"Girl, You Know It's True,"
and it didn't start early.
It skipped.
That's how they caught
Milli Vanilli.
And I think,
if you've ever watched it,
it is -- it's crazy, because
they know in the moment
they're screwed.
And it went a little bit
like this.
[ Mouthing ]
♪ Girl, you know it's true ♪
♪ True, true, true, true, true,
true, true, true, true ♪
♪ True, true, true, true, true ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ I love you ♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people have been
saying, "Where's Wally?"
We're not talking about
Wally enough,
I guess, on the show.
And, um...
[ Laughter ]
But we do try
to keep an eye out for Wally,
to try to answer
that question, "Where's Wally?"
You might remember H.R.-gate...
[ Laughter ]
...where Wally joined a Zoom
about H.R.,
Behavior in the Workplace,
and, uh...
chose to do it in bed --
just a tiny little head
in the corner of the frame.
And we've given him a lot --
you know, we've given him
a lot of stick about that,
and I think it was time
to move on.
But then Wally was discovered
waiting for his COVID
test results.
I did not take these photos.
[ Laughter ]
But I had them sent to me.
Wally once again
just making himself comfortable.
[ Laughter ]
Just look at --
If we can zoom in,
just how happy Wally is.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
And I was like,
"What were you --
What were you
on the phone doing?"
You know what he told me?
"I was doing my makeup H.R."
[ Laughter ]
Also, we talked about a --
that Trump would make
a hurricane wall in Texas
out of -- out of Werther's --
"Verter's" --
and people pointed out that if
you made a hurricane wall --
This is what graphics
made for us.
A hurricane wall --
You would want to make
a hurricane wall
against the ocean.
That's where the hurricane
would come from.
And instead, what they did is,
they made like a cage
to catch the hurricane...
[ Laughter ]
...and keep it from dissipating
and spreading out
into other states.
So basically your friends
from graphics
sentenced Texas to death.
[ Laughter ]
All right, I'm gonna --
I'm not gonna call him anymore.
I'm just gonna write Andy
and see if he's around.
Uh...
"I'm just gonna do this now.
You're on for 'Corrections,'"
but I also want to read
what he texted me last week,
obviously, during "Corrections."
He wrote, "I'm naked.
Just got out of shower.
Tell them I got Queen Bee."
And then we finished
"Corrections,"
and I was leaving,
and he wrote again,
"Did you tell them?"
Very important.
And then I wrote, "I did."
And he wrote,
"But did you couch it in a burn?
I'm fine with it either way."
And then I wrote,
"There was an eyeroll,
but I did say it like you
wrote it," which I did.
I read it exactly that.
And he wrote,
"And that I was naked?"
Question mark, question mark,
question mark.
And I wrote, "Yeah."
And then Andy wrote,
"Did everyone get boners?"
[ Laughter ]
"Did everyone get boners???"
And I wrote,
"I'll follow up next week."
And he wrote, "Joke's on them.
If they did, I look like crap."
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Last thing.
Might not hear back from him.
Probably should have
texted him earlier.
You know, like I said,
I'm out of sorts today.
This is very lovely, though.
And I think it speaks
to a kind of best and worst
of what we're dealing with
with our -- with this whole --
I don't know --
this whole thing.
Someone wrote, "If there's
anyone from the Late Night team
reading this --"
there was -- me --
"Seth was supposed to perform
in Manchester, New Hampshire,
right as COVID started --"
true --
"and the show was postponed."
Also true.
"When it was rescheduled,
like a year and a half later,
my best friend that was supposed
to go with me the first time
couldn't make it.
And I asked a friend/co-worker
who has a really great sense
of humor to come with me
last-minute.
He and I
are now getting married in July.
And it is a direct result
of hanging out at the show.
Thank you, Seth,
for giving me my husband."
So lovely.
And I just want to say
congratulations to you both.
This wasn't the right place
to write that.
[ Laughter ]
Now we have, of course,
good people
amongst the jackals
who live in the comments.
One of them wrote,
"This is lovely.
Hope you find all the happiness
in the world together."
Appropriate.
Kind of thing you should say.
Another jackal thought,
"Oh, they want to know
what I think."
They wrote,
"You're getting married
after less than a year
of dating?"
[ Laughter ]
Bro, take it up with me.
But leave those people alone.
But then there's my
favorite kind of people,
which is the jackals
for the jackals,
who wrote, "They're co-workers.
They've probably known
each other a few years."
[ Laughter ]
Mostly, I'm just
very happy for them.
I'm sorry we don't have Samberg.
Hold on.
I'm gonna try my other one.
[ FaceTime ringing ]
This person lives in L.A.,
and last week, after -- after --
'cause I don't plan ahead,
I wrote, "Hey, I called you
for 'Corrections,'"
and they said,
"Oh, remember, I'm in L.A.
I was probably asleep."
And I was like,
"Well, we do it at 5:00."
[ Laughter ]
And they said, "Yeah."
We had a lot of fun today.
We're going to come back
hard next week and...
I'm pretty happy about this one.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
We'll see you next week.